[Music]
i'm going to show you
a couple pictures of the same person and
on drugs and not on drugs i like those
me too
yeah does it drugs change your little
[ __ ] everything yeah i like it when
they're like
down and out and they're just oh [ __ ]
you
like it mine is a reverse when they were
[ __ ] like uh
what the [ __ ] when they were on drugs
too then they're recovered
oh the other way around it's like they
were shitty so they took drugs and now
they're like killing it yeah well the
pictures i'm showing you
don't have anything you like success
stories i like downfall stories
downfall stars are pretty good it's kind
of like precautionary tales
cautionary tales i like when they get
ran over yep oh [ __ ]
by what like roll runner life wiley
coyote you just see like two tire marks
across
yeah when they're flat they're flattened
out yeah
i actually saw a bird like that a pigeon
[ __ ]
they had a tire track over it was it a
now's dead
it's not funny why are you laughing
look at his face it's kind of funny it's
pain
it's clearly painful yes okay here we go
hoping my question to you with these
photos is
she's on a cliff what ethnicity do you
think she is kind of puerto rican
don't make me sound racist well i mean
this this one does go into
the race territory for sure mix race
mixed race how about that folks same
person
yeah middle eastern middle eastern maybe
no clue she is very ambiguous
like a witch indian like a witch she
looks like a fortune telling witch
she's a fortune teller if i was a
casting director i could see
indian middle eastern maybe even like a
darker tone italian
yeah latin it's here in so many
different ways
she looks like she [ __ ] mixes [ __ ] in
a cauldron
it's a dark lipstick would you cast her
as
a black person if you're casting nah
cause she's casting spells homie
that's [ __ ] good okay
so yes damn it 10
10 out of 10. killing it today
all right so this person she is a
professor
her name is jessica krug and she's been
lying
about being black no another
another rachel dolezal god what a dog
another one i'm trying to figure out how
long she was lying for she was lying for
like pretty much her entire life
if she said she was like a quarter or a
half maybe i don't know so is she like
about to stretch my imagination a little
bit yeah she's walking around just
dropping n bombs
damn no she she specializes in um what
does she do
i forget american
[Laughter]
she specializes in fraud
[Laughter]
no she teaches uh african-american
studies
[Applause]
it is really another rachel dolezal
because she was like the
like someone really prominent in the
naacp or something right yes yes yeah
yeah but you know what's crazy is for
rachel dallas i was
reading up about her again that uh a lot
of a lot of most people
i hear so this is from rachel dolezal
herself most people i hear
from are black or mixed or non-white in
some way and a lot of people have said
this is your moment you're vindicated
like like she's been met with a lot of
positive messages
when she came out as a white person for
some reason
but on the other hand uh jessica krug
though
is a different story how do people find
out like her 23andme came in or
something
uh no i you know she doesn't look black
to me at all
rachel dolezal kind of passed a little
bit yeah like the hair and all the light
skin
maybe but you can't tell yeah that's
true
so for jessica krug she's um
published books about you know life as a
black person
wow lots of stuff yeah oh she's crazy
and how she
got discovered though was um there's a
few scholars within
like i guess that world like like just
african-american studies and stuff that
we're just kind of like questioning like
you
always seem to be very adamant about
proving your blackness
and and like in like just you know if
you're black like you don't
go over and beyond to prove it you know
you're just you are black
so a lot of people were just kind of
like curious as to why she
always had to overcompensate and and
they just referenced this as
uh research they researched her and
basically confronted her and i guess she
got found it out
and before they could bring the news to
to media or whatever
she out of herself she she outed herself
and she i canceled myself
and she made a whole you can't do that
you [ __ ]
you got to let them do it for you now
shady [ __ ] but does it work
if you cancel yourself does it work like
is it working she's like you can't fire
me i fire myself
no that's not it i think it has its own
back i mean you're definitely canceling
yourself for sure but then there's also
like it's like a double cancel yeah but
what's the lesser of two evils
her doing it herself it's lesser because
it's like oh at least you have the
decency to do but it's like nah [ __ ] no
you didn't because you got a cop
yeah how do you cosplay a race so
hard that you believe that you're
that race like that's that's a crazy
level that's some identity issues
it is so this is her statement she said
mental health issues likely explain why
i assumed a false identity
initially as a youth and why i continued
and developed it for so long
when i was a teenager fleeing trauma i
could just run away to a new place and
become a new person but this isn't
trauma that anyone imposed on me
this is harm that i have enacted on to
so many others there is nowhere to run i
have ended the life i had no right to
live in the first place so
i think it's also kind of like in this
climate
that we're in right now it's for her i
think she's just
i don't know i think she's really got
her back uh back against the ropes right
now does she have kids
cut her black against the rope right now
huh
she have kids and is married i does not
say if she has
kids i do not know why would anyone want
to do that that's so weird
like self-hatred self-hatred yeah so
much that you want to be a different
culture
yeah it happens a lot too like you know
where people
renounce their own culture to
try to fit into a different culture all
the time true
do you feel like there's um something to
and
again i want to assume but is there
something to maybe like a sympathy
element that like because she's like oh
i'm also black and she's a
an african-american studies that
you know what i mean it's like not only
am i a part of this but like the same
struggles or trials and tribulations
that like i am teaching and preaching
about like i've also enjoyed myself
you know what i mean so therefore like
treat me with respect huh you know what
i'm saying i'm not saying anything
credibility i'm just wondering if it's
like right it's like it's like i'll
pretend to be handicapped in some way
i'm not saying that like as if
you know being black as a handicap but
like maybe in the things and the
subjects of what
she has and the lifestyle which she's
like kind of like she has the right to
speak on it
yeah right but she chose that lie in her
teens yeah so it would make sense if she
was like just into african-american
studies and then realized
maybe it will make my argument stronger
if i just say i'm black right
versus someone in her teens
claiming to be black so hard that
they're like i'm gonna dedicate my life
to blackness and i'm gonna go
and study african american studies and
doing all this and then helping the
cause or whatever she thinks it is
um it to me it seems like the
the lie started at a very early age yeah
and it could be
that maybe she saw that black
being black you can you can say certain
things like
yeah this happened to me and our people
or whatever
versus like if she's white she doesn't
have that same
type of way to express or say that we
went through something
right it's kind of like the opposite of
white privilege like if you can say that
there's like a black privilege
i don't think it's called privilege i
don't yeah that's not the word
she probably sees that other cultures
can talk about certain things in their
history
that happen and maybe she wanted that
attention or whatever it is
because it's not the same for white
people
like they can't um
talk about their struggle the same way
we can
right because they are the oppressor
right so then so for example like when
you're
a part of the oppressive group it sounds
like
oh yeah right when you say anything
about it
right so then maybe in her eyes
having that kind of power or tension she
the grass was greener yeah you know it's
kind of like when we look at rich kids
and be like man
i wish i had that and you pretend like
kids will pretend to be rich
right so like i think she probably saw
whatever it was in the black community
as something she really wanted
and then she couldn't stop herself from
lying to get that
yeah interesting so what is her she is
white she's jewish
she's white jewish yeah so another
another quote from her
to an escalating degree over my adult
life i have eschewed my
my lived experience as a white jewish
child in suburban kansas city under
various assumed identities within a
blackness that i had no right to claim
and so she and she went through phases
of this too so first
uh she pulls her she was north african
blackness
then u.s rooted blackness then caribbean
rooted
bronx blackness so did she change her
accents too
i think so i have no idea what any like
north african blackness like i don't
under i don't know what that is but it
sounds like she's taking on different
variations of black whichever one like
fits her better
just do something like a normal team
like be a skater
you know what i mean like take on a
personality of a great [ __ ] skateboards
i'm trying to be moroccan today
yeah what sounds like what about like
something that
can actually happen like i drowned
before
you know right maybe she could get
sympathy from being a drown victim
or maybe she should just see a [ __ ]
psychologist through it it seems like
she wanted attention
yeah sure it's kind of like she wanted
to and that's so
[ __ ] up to do that because you're kind
of fetishizing a whole entire race and
then she made her life's
dedication and infiltrated this and
created
like works of like just like like
academic [ __ ] right so like people are
studying her [ __ ] things
like it's real so everybody was fed
her fraudulent behavior yeah kind of
came in
and created damage to the
african-american culture and community
because she
contributed false [ __ ] that's like if
somebody came in
and said like i'm japanese american and
then they wrote like all these books and
all that and everyone's like oh man that
work of art was so strong and good
and then later you find out like his
real name was hector gonzalez
and you know he wasn't even japanese you
know he was ecuadorian or something
and then it's like oh what the [ __ ] how
did you know so much about japan
yeah where did you get the info from
then like i based my my life is a lie
like [ __ ] dude he was our [ __ ]
activist or whatever
you think she'd be like
native american or something like that
open a casino take something you know i
mean
really advantageous for herself but
right no she just wanted attention
that's all it is and now she's getting
it yeah yeah she's getting even more
attention by coming out but the bad one
right bad attention
bad one yeah so like she's basically
lost a lot of credibility in her
and her work uh a lot of her colleagues
are no longer friends with her and and
even a lot of colleagues were saying
like yeah there was something
you know fraudulent or like something
you know fishy that that was just you
know they they could sense it
but never they never knew what it was
but now that she knows so much about
african-american studies can she teach
it as a white lady now
perhaps that has you know there's like
white professors that teach asian
american studies too
that's true yeah i don't think you have
to be that racist her knowledge of it
is still there like she's still gaining
the knowledge she just can't teach it
from a personal experience but then i
think she loses all credibility when you
become a fraud
she lied about her experiences and so
like
you can't really trust their opinions
or anything true and she lived his life
to the fullest so
another another excerpt that she wrote
there's no parallel form of my adulthood
connected to white people or white
community
or an alternative white identity i have
lived this life
fully completely with no exit plan or
strategy
i have no identity outside of this i
have never developed one
like she she got problems and in the
next thing you see she went goth
she needs dmt yeah there we go find
herself what if she finds like a for
real like a black soul from like a
reincarnated past or something like that
oh then we're all dicks
we take dmt and there's just dicks
inside our soldier yeah we are there so
many penises in here
what i i don't know she might identify
as a dinosaur next or something
crazy crazy crazy that [ __ ] is nuts
[Music]
do